not much appears to keep this child down
from their home in north korea this
boy's father says he's just getting over
covert 19.
for kids they tend to move a lot even if
they have a fever so they just run
around and play for 30 minutes
the nation is experiencing what local
media are calling an explosive outbreak
until last week pyongyang didn't admit
anything was wrong now it's reporting
dozens of people have died
on sunday the country's leader kim
jong-un made it known he's taking the
matter seriously visiting pharmacies and
wearing a mask in public something he
rarely did before
the world health organization offered
inoculations last year but kim rejected
it
earlier that day he held the third
cabinet meeting in one week to create an
action plan against the rampant spread
of the virus
there kim criticized government
officials for their handling of the
crisis saying state drugs were not
reaching people fast enough and most
pharmacies were in poor condition
we have shifted from the previous
quarantine oriented system to a
treatment-oriented system the most
important thing in this switch is the
thorough control of the situation
although south korea considers its
northern neighbour a nuclear threat its
new president has offered to help
if north korea responds we will spare no
medicines including covet 19 vaccines
medical equipment and health personnel
so far the most isolated nation on earth
has refused outside help
leaving many relying on painkillers to
battle the effects of covert 19
but even those seem to be in short
supply
laura berdimani al jazeera